hi there I just finished my workout here
I have a few minutes here before dinner
quick shower and dinner I just want to
update you on what I've been doing today
this morning I did a certain amount of
reading but mostly reading of patterns
and that's the focus of the video today
is patterns
I believe language learning consists of
on the one hand a lot of exposure to
meaningful content which hopefully you
know as soon as could possible you can
move into sort of interesting authentic
content that grips you but the other
part of it is is getting used to the
patterns of the language and I'm going
to show you some of the material that
I've used and today I did a lot of
reading of these basic patterns and then
while working out now listening to them
I had a few other things that I had to
do today I was interviewed by the way
for 40 minutes by a journalist about
language learning so I had to spend time
and I'm always happy to explain my views
on language learning I was asked what I
thought of speak from day one as a
strategy and I told the reporter and the
other thing is that while I focused on
patterns as I will show you I also did
some basic linking on link reading some
more articles from Chosun Ilbo and
discovered that my neighbor Korean
dictionary is is actually a tremendous
dictionary and it has a number of other
sort of subsets of that dictionary which
we are going to now link with you know
connect to link so that I can more
easily find the Chinese characters that
are associated with these words that I'm
looking up because that's gonna speed up
my vocabulary acquisition but the
articles I read had to do with the
disputes between Korea and Japan on
little islands and references to history
and to the present government in Japan
and their approach to their own history
and very interesting subjects that deal
with the whole history of the last
hundred years between Japan and China so
I'm looking forward to getting into that
but today I focused on patterns and
that's what I'm gonna show you let me
explain what I mean by patterns this is
an excellent book for patterns it says
hung little bumble humble grammar Korean
Korean grammar in Japanese
the book is full of patterns it
describes a particular pattern Oh or
tooth dot and then it gives you examples
and that's all it does in the whole book
a very little grammatical explanation
which is perfect for me and it just
literally hundreds and hundreds of
examples of all these different patterns
I read through it I forget what I read
it has the Japanese translation which is
helpful and then I listen to it and then
I of course don't get it all when I
listen and then I go back and read and I
spent a good hour and a half reading
this book today and and then listening
to it listening to while I was
exercising and I listen to it a lot many
times they're still still essentially
the same places that I that I don't
understand I keep reading keep listening
today is day 14 so it's the end of the
second week of my 90 days of the 13
weeks if I keep doing this I'm going to
basically ingrain the basic patterns of
Korean into my mind another book that
helps me on my pursuit of patterns is
this continuing Korean which was
produced here at UBC it has some good
and some bad
you know the dialogues are much better
than the average beginner book the sound
quality is excellent some of the
problems are that it has a bit too much
grammatical explanation for my taste
you know it introduces terms like
retrospective modifier you know I can
learn Korean without ever knowing what a
retrospective modifier is similar stuff
I was trying to find some typical
examples of this
it does have examples but you just have
to skip through a lot of this other
stuff whereas I had some other examples
here we are you know the copula intimate
style
okay intima style I can deal with copula
a little more difficult I'm quite sure
what they're talking about there then
they have a bunch of you know please
like chewy like pay attention here you
know plain style question and being
differs from the sequential ending
in that it is a one shape ending etc etc
my experience is that we are much better
able you know copula transfer rented
what is that we are much better able to
deal with examples the brain will form
rules and create patterns and so we need
a lot of exposure to the patterns and
that's why typically in all of these
books where they have questions I just
go to the back and look up the answers
because typically the answers will be a
concentration of examples of whatever
pattern they're trying to drill you on I
don't like doing drills but I like
looking at the examples
colloquial Korean very quickly was a
book that I used when I started he
doesn't have a lot of examples of
patterns the audio is okay but it's full
of English which I don't like
so literally I can't listen to it more
than once because there's English on it
so it serves its purpose as an initial
walkthrough but in terms of in grading
patterns it's not as good as continuing
Korean which has a lot of patterns in it
once you get past the grammatical
explanations or skip over it and this
Japanese book which probably is only
useful for people who know Japanese but
patterns are key and and so while I'm a
great believer in input based learning
and building up your vocabulary and I'm
going to put a lot of effort in that
effort in that in order to be able to
speak I need to have a better grasp of
my patterns oh and by the way I spoke to
Tudor last night I tried to record it it
didn't work again but I think I've
solved the problem I'm speaking to a
tutor again tonight and I'll try to show
you a bit of the video of our discussion
thanks for listening